[Music]
hello from Google cloud next nineteen in
beautiful San Francisco where tens of
thousands are gathered to build a club
for everyone
I'm Stephanie Wong and I'm reto Meier
we'll be with you throughout the next
two days of Google cloud next nineteen
bringing you keynote recaps interviews
with Google experts and some very cool
product demos if you miss anything along
the way fear not you can catch up
anytime at gto slash next on air the
next on our live stream experience is
crafted to dive deeper into content that
matters to you most beyond the next live
show we've got five over three channels
streaming simultaneously two with some
keys for the cloud universe build run
analyze and learn secure and collaborate
all available to you on your preferred
device at home in yesterday's keynote we
heard all about modernization with
Google cloud today's keynote took us a
step further focusing on infrastructure
insight and innovation director of cloud
AR strategy and operations Tracy Feith
is here with us to tell us more Tracy
give us the highlights from today's
keynote so I think one of the most
exciting things is that we're really
starting to see how customers are
leveraging the cloud and building cloud
strategy no matter where they're
starting whether that's starting from
on-prem hybrid all of these things are
now available and we as an overall cloud
organization have been working really
hard to make it incredibly easy for
customers to start where they are and
leverage our products and services to
really update their infrastructure and
drive innovation for their companies
that was really clear to me today and it
was really exciting to see it all come
together now ai is embedded in
everything we do what are you most
excited for about AI and Google cloud
and other parts of Google you know it's
a little bit of a similar answer to be
honest so over the last year and a half
I've spoken with hundreds of customers
and everybody is really excited about AI
but a lot of organizations don't know
what that means
and they don't know how AI can impact
their business and the business problems
that they're facing today
and we've been working really hard to
create a set of products and solutions
and services that can help address some
of those mission-critical problems very
easily for customers and so I'm really
excited to see some of those examples
really start to come to life
things like Salesforce working with Hulu
on our contact center our natural
language processes being a part of the
Einstein bot you know things like what
Baker Hughes she is doing with our cloud
AI platform it's really exciting to see
these tactical examples of how AI can
impact an enterprise absolutely we saw a
lot of great demos showing Google cloud
products at work how are these new
products helping our customers manage
data reliably and securely so they can
modernize scale and can really be
successful if you look at what we saw in
the smart analytics demo you could
really see the end-to-end experience for
customers and that's a lot of where the
pain has been so for example in cloudy I
we own kaggle which is the world's
largest community of data scientists and
they often joke that data scientists
will say that 90% of the pain and
machine learning is cleaning the data
and 10% is complaining about cleaning
the data and that is an experience that
I think anybody who has worked to
extract insights from their data can
relate to because it can be
extraordinarily painful and when you see
all of the products that are coming
together across our smart analytics
platform everything from bigquery and
data fusion all of those pieces auto ml
tables you can start to see how easy it
can be for customers to extract those
insights at scale very quickly and
speaking of these features that help our
data analytics workflows we saw some
great demos highlighting some new
features like cloud data fusion bakeware
EBI engine and auto ml tables how can
developers scientists and analysts apply
these to support their hybrid workloads
so I can speak specifically to Auto ml
tables because that's the product that
our team works on and one of the things
that I have really loved about the auto
ml suite is that you really doesn't
require machine learning expertise to
use it and at the same time
it's an extraordinarily helpful tool for
people who are machine learning experts
and builders and it has the ability to
stretch across those populations and
make it really useful for anybody we
have heard over and over that structured
data is a real challenge for customers
and so being able to leverage something
like auto ml tables where customers can
start to piece together information from
disparate data sets build them all
together allow machine learning models
to be created for you through the auto
ml tool without having to write any code
it just is really exciting to see what
that can do absolutely can you give us
some examples from today's keynote of
how our viewers will be able to use
machine learning and Google AI
especially those in companies just
starting out who may not already have a
lot of ml experience yeah absolutely
so there are a couple problems that
we've heard from customers that are
really common across the landscape of
enterprise customers a top one is in
contact centers and customer service and
this is a challenge that almost every
organization I've spoken with faces in
some form or fashion Rai has worked
really hard to enhance the human agents
who are working in contact centers give
them everything they need at their
fingertips in a really efficient and
beautiful way and what we've done there
is integrate our AI with the key players
in the contact center space so that it
doesn't require customers to do a full
rip and replace on hardware they've
already purchased and so that's a very
easy way to get started we've also heard
from almost every customer that another
area that they really struggle with is
dark data and that exists in documents
that are both physical documents digital
documents the challenge if you can you
know if you think about a paper that you
read or a PDF where you have graphs and
tables and all kinds of information and
the the ability to actually be able to
extract those pieces those components
using AI make sense of them and then
pull insights out of that through our
document understanding AI we really
believe is going to help customers gain
efficiency and information much faster
and that's another way that I think
would be great for customers to get
started that we've seen
they know many people may know that we
build AI into a lot of our products like
G suite Google Maps how can our
customers use those tools to build their
innovative features into their own tools
and products so we offer a range of
products everywhere from pre trained
api's to auto imel's where you can
customize to meet your specific needs
through to our code AI platform where
you can very easily build your own
machine learning models if you have that
expertise and so across that range
there's an opportunity for customers to
really be able to leverage the power of
Google AI in almost every business
problem they face and that can be very
exciting and it can be a little bit
daunting if you don't know exactly where
to get started and so we are offering a
number of solutions through things like
our professional services organization
for customers who aren't sure where to
start
we can help them and then we have a
series of demos of tools all kinds of
information that you can gather to
really help you figure out where AI can
help make your business better
so was the director of AI strategy is
there anything you can tell us about
what we can look forward to in the near
future that's a great question so I
think you know what's top of mind for me
is all of the ways that we can make AI
easier for companies to use how we can
help them scale their businesses and so
you know we are spending a lot of time
in really building that ease-of-use into
everything we offer another area that
you will likely start to see from us is
continuing our efforts around explain
ability so I really firmly believe that
in order for AI to be successful it
really has to be trusted and in order
for it to be trusted it has to be built
and deployed and thought of responsibly
and part of that is about understanding
what is in those machine learning models
and how they're making decisions and so
we have a lot of exciting efforts around
explain ability and interpretability
I also mean Trust is such an important
feature in all the things that we do
that's right
Tracy thank you so much for helping us
understand the power of AI to improve
our work you're so welcome I'm glad to
be here
now if you've got a question or a
comment on today's keynote or about our
talk with Tracy reach out to us on
social media using the hashtag Google
next maintainer and next there are lots
of opportunities to get one-on-one
learning and hands-on time with our
products in the dev zone we sent our
reporter mock merchandani over to the
dead zone to check it out mock tell us
what's happening over there hey everyone
we're here at the Google cloud next
Developer zone this is full of cool
little showcases hands-on labs tutorials
and of course the dead zone stage where
people are able to come here and learn
all about the cool things but really get
their hands on them and play around with
them speaking of which
we're at the BQ ML station with Felipe
Hoffa who loves data and bigquery so
Felipe tell me a little bit more about
what we're looking at here hi mark
so what we have here is a stack overflow
predictor how long will it take for
people to answer your question so what
does that mean specifically so I can go
in the stack overflow I can ask a
question but someone's not gonna respond
immediately
yeah so I don't know if you ever asked a
question will stack overflow it takes
some time and you never know how long
will it take well with this tool we can
kind of predict how long will it take
looking at all the past data that we
have from stack overflow now how do you
do that because bigquery you can do a
bunch of data analysis but you can't
build a machine learning model in
bigquery right well you can now so I
love the query I love that analytics
thanks to the public data program we
have a copy of Stack Overflow the damn
table they publish
reporter so we load the data in bigquery
and then you can start running your own
sequel queries over it anyone can come
and run any query they want they have a
free terabyte every month so the first
step with that analytics is just to look
at all your questions look at all your
answers and get an average of how long
did it take for people to answer
questions on Stack Overflow so people
can come here to the next shell cache
floor play around with this interface
here change and see if they ask a
question and then based on the machine
learning model don't see about how long
they'd have to wait for someone to go
and answer it exactly so how did we go
from the analytics of just average group
by to a prediction and there's a lot of
spaces in between right for example to
get an answer for the Google bigquery
tag 8:00 a.m. for a medium question that
ends with a person end with a question
mark that starts with a y for someone
that creates an account in 2017 we're
predicting that it will take 53 minutes
maybe they will not get an answer but
with an 85 percent probability they will
get one and they there is a chance of
being downloaded of about a seven
percent for these statistics now how do
we build this we used we created a
linear regression using all of these
features and the data that we have
available so with all this different
information you can know when you ask a
question approximately hopefully pretty
relatively when it's gonna be answered
but you could also maybe even predict
when's the best time to ask a question
exactly if you want to go the opposite
way so let's say it takes 53 minutes or
not you say on Sunday it takes more like
an hour to get an answer but there's a
higher chance of getting an answer so
lots of cool information to play around
with here but people can also come here
and actually learn B qml hands-on right
exactly so there are two alternatives
for people that are not here to see how
I made this they can go to my blog post
on medium just search for Felipe Hoffa
when will Stack Overflow reply and if
you are here and next we have laughs
ready for you to run that you can also
find online but there are some many ways
to learn and get your hands into this
perfect so lots of cool stuff for me qml
come down to the floor get started or
check out the resources online hi I'm
Natalie and we are in the intelligence
neighborhood in the sounds and models
demo and I'm joined here by you Thank
You Fang tell us a little bit about what
you do and this awesome demo that you've
created here we have station one
gathering data and we have this kind of
instrument if you will but it's actually
five instruments and so each string
represents a different instrument and we
can plot our string to make different
sounds and what we're gonna do is use
this as our kind of data source the
sounds are going to then go into data
flow and get converted into spectrogram
they're gonna get moved into this the
frequency space and those images can
then be used to train our model the hope
is that these images will be distinct
enough to be able to represent each
exactly that we can tell them apart that
we can distinguish between instrument
one two three four and five
oh okay so we've got our training data
now it's time to start trading the model
so with auto ml we can train models
using the data that we had but then we
don't have to do any extra work so you
can see here that the data is coming in
and you can see those are the some of
the spectrograms those are the real data
that attendees have generated over the
course of today
images of the sound waves that's right
these are the spectrograms and then when
you train a model it just does the
training there's not much kind of work
you have to do and when it finishes
training you can have some evaluation
data that shows you the metrics around
how well the model trained and how it
did so if you're new to ml that's a
great space to get started alright it's
an easy tool to get going with and if
you have some data you want to you know
throw it photo on that vision it'll take
care of it for you Haiden go do
something else with your time so we have
this board here where you can move these
kind of sliders around to different
positions and they map to different
values on the screen which changed the
values of type of parameters of the
actual models things like kernel width
and height the layer size
the number of strides as well as the
kind of number of layers you have not
actual life teeth
change the amount of code on the screen
once we're happy with you know a set of
settings that we have we can go ahead
and push the button here and start a
training job and doing that well it'll
assign us a name something fun like
spinto kappa and shoot that off to cube
flow where we have a pipeline to do
training and when it finished the
training we'll deploy it on the cloud
platform prediction service so time to
moves to stage 3 I'm speaking of
prediction alright final stage now and
that's to predict the notes yes and so
we're gonna try to pull up the model
that we've been training it's spin so
cap it's there for us so you can turn
the crank as a selector and then press
the red button to select it select so
this is kind of like a customizable
music box and we can choose which notes
to play on which instrument you can hit
the button again so you know and this
countdown then will be able to turn this
crank now so these are these are the
notes that we set up we're gonna send
those notes off to the cloud platform
prediction service now how did we do
right was our model any good we chose
those parameters kind of randomly and so
it might be good it might not be so good
we'll we'll see right you got some of
them it seemed like it might have
actually missed a bunch it did and so
you know this is part of the machine
learning workflow this particular case a
pretty abysmal outcome because that's a
lot of machine learning right it's all
part of the process so I think this is a
perfect demonstration to show that so
you think thank you so much for this
demonstration I think I was very clear
in kind of the three stages of what to
expect when witch training machine
learning models so thank you so much my
pleasure thanks so much our way in
see this year we're bringing some of the
showcase experiments home to you cloud
showcase online lets you explore and get
hands-on creative code experiences with
google cloud including the bee qml
experiment familiar check out GT o-- /
showcase slash experiments to start
riffing on our code the next round of
sessions is coming up shortly join us
back here after that when we'll be
talking kubernetes and checking out more
dev zone experiments and showcase demos
from next 19
[Music]
welcome back to the next live show I'm
Stephanie Wong joining us now is
jennifer lynn product management
director thank you so much for joining
us thanks for having me so for those
viewers who are just learning about
kubernetes and borg can you explain what
each of those is and how we're making
kubernetes easier to consume and the
significance of how each has evolved at
Google sure kubernetes is the
externalization and the open source of
our internal controller development
container orchestration tool called Borg
it's something that we've evolved over
the last decade and we have said
publicly that we launched four billion
containers a week across the Google
environment so managing that at scale
we've learned a lot about just running
large global scale systems and doing
container orchestration at scale in a
resilient reliable way kubernetes was
open sourced a few years ago and we've
had our own managed version of
kubernetes with google kubernetes engine
now over four years so a lot has
happened in a very short period of time
but there's lots of lessons learned
under the covers we continue to talk
about API services and open source why
is Google differentiating in this space
yeah I think you know this industry is
changing so fast developers writing new
software so it's really important that
we get the interfaces and how do we
enable the lifecycle management of
services right as a you know system and
I think that's why kubernetes has also
gained a lot of traction very quickly it
sort of makes the notion of a service a
first-class citizen and we've been very
clear about how to api's interact and
how do we essentially define services
and do the lifecycle management of
services and that's all coming with the
maturity of things like kubernetes and
SEO yeah and this is all enabling our
developers a lot of developers want to
approach the way that Google doesn't
dive in and get experience the way that
Google develops software how does open
source enable the community and empower
the community yeah I think open source
has been the reason why a lot of this
has moved so quickly I mean it feels
like overnight it has become kubernetes
has become sort of the container
orchestration system of choice just a
few years ago there were so many there
was a lot of fragmentation a lot of
folks understood the value proposition
of containerization with docker but
essentially managing that at scale at
the system level there were various
options through open source I think
we've allowed a lot of people to just
number one understand what's going on
number two contribute in a way that's
meaningful for them and get a lot of the
use cases out there in the open so we
can iterate on best practices etc and
you know yes a lot of this has been very
focused on developer agility but now as
we move into sort of the maturity of it
yes a lot of the practices for the
operational administrators and sres and
making this essentially a production
level system is a lot of what the
community is excited about as well
that's great yeah open source is really
focused on our users and we also want to
build our user experience into our
products can you talk a little bit more
about that and given that our cloud
users are different and they have
different needs how do we build that
into our products as well yeah I mean on
the product side within Google we do a
lot with the user research team to just
make sure we understand who are the
personas whether it's developer or a
security administrator or a network
administrator or the IT professional or
the user so just making sure we taking
sort of a use case driven approach and
understanding sort of who is the user of
the product and essentially you know
what problem are they trying to solve
and how do we hide the complexity and
make it a lot easier and make sure that
they're essentially doing their job well
but there are a lot because this is a
software stack with a lot of you know
we've talked a lot about decoupling and
separation of concerns you can have a
unified stack but you have to recognize
that there's lots of folks that
essentially are consumers of that stack
so what's your advice for those who want
to move to the cloud with acceleration
and not have to do a rip and replace and
manage their existing lifecycle how do
they bring in cloud native yeah I think
cloud native has really been about sort
of openness and you know the flexibility
that we talked about today with with em
DOS is really there are an architectural
set of principles which I think
kubernetes and things like sto have kind
of put out there in the open source
community there's a framework and then
there's an implementation so number one
I think the industry is really rallying
around the fact that container
orchestration there's sort of a clear
you know de-facto standard there
obviously we have our managed version of
that because there's a lot beyond just
the software bits in terms of how do you
actually you know do lifecycle
management and keep essentially you know
automatic upgrades patching security
updates etc as part of this system and
so that developers can move quickly but
you can keep essentially the security
and stability of the system
right and one big part of the
acceleration is GK on-prem which was
announced last August and this is the
first time we've actually brought our
technology into the data center at this
scale so why now and why not sooner
yeah I mean what we found is everybody
understands the benefits of cloud but in
many cases there's technical and
non-technical reasons why they can't
move all their workloads into cloud
overnight so this was a lot about
bringing the best of the kubernetes you
know stack and what we're doing with
Google cloud to the on-prem environment
and helping people move at their own
pace while at the same time modernizing
in place so it's not just about renting
compute cycles it's actually about
application modernization and developing
new services and adding more business
value etc so we're pretty excited about
that now it's not just on our GCP
resources but we can essentially run
this on you know third-party servers in
a private data center for the enterprise
and as we talked about today other
environments as well
so speaking of modernization we loved
your demo during the day one keynote
thank you we heard a lot about
modernizing in place this year can you
talk about how anthos enables you to
modernize your applications no matter
where they are as you mentioned
on-premises or in the cloud yeah I think
that's the nice thing about you know
kubernetes is you know with anthos we're
really thinking about sort of open api's
so that the interfaces between those
environments number one we can hide the
complexity but still keep a consistent
management environment for the
developers independent of where those
workloads run they can learn you know
one set of tools and essentially evolve
as the industry evolves without picking
sort of exactly where that's going to
run or you know what production
environment it's going to run in because
many developers don't know they want to
write once run anywhere their consumers
may be running in many many clouds and
similarly for the platform administrator
they don't have to learn a bunch of
different vendor tools this framework is
here to stay we believe it's going to
you know be the standard for many years
to come so even if that's not running in
Google's cloud per se that skill set
that many enterprises are trying to hire
people who understand kubernetes that's
very portable so people are willing to
invest in it now because it's it's going
to be here to stay for for many years
and on that theme we're hearing that
developers and operators want to be
managing at higher levels of the stack
but they still want visibility and
controller for policy management at a
service level
how is anthos providing a unified
programming model
monitoring and policy across on-premise
and multiple clouds yeah great question
I mean with kubernetes obviously we've
really thought about container
orchestration and cluster administration
at scale you know with this deal we're
thinking about assuming most of your
micro services are now containerized how
do you look out for the lifecycle and
health of those services and the
interactions between those services how
do you make sure that those services are
authenticated and and that you can put
essentially policies around those
services without having to manage the
underlying infrastructure complexity and
then we showed how we're doing config
management and automating essentially
configurations at scale in a way that
essentially is declarative so you can
define the policies once and push them
down to different environments and you
don't have to rewrite them with a lot of
toil for each cloud environment and
that's really important for customers
that are thinking about let's say you
know PCI compliance or governance those
rules around how to have those security
controls in place don't change cloud to
cloud but today they're spending a lot
of time just to make sure they can you
know ensure audit and compliance in each
different environment so we believe that
sort of extra overhead that doesn't need
to be there and that was a key push with
without those many of our enterprise
customers they want to embrace new
technologies but it's not easy to figure
out how do I ensure that I'm still
reducing my costs keeping the efficiency
and you know addressing what the
auditors and compliance regulatory
environments are looking for right and
we actually know that not everybody has
a luxury of moving to the cloud
immediately for whatever reason how can
we help them get there yeah I think a
lot of it is I mean this has been a
great week so far I think the partner
community is very engaged I think a lot
of the use cases and the best practices
that are being put out there are based
on you know folks trying things out you
know sharing best practices we're trying
to take more of a use case driven
approach with enthis I think a lot of
what we're trying to share is the
operational domain knowledge and the
best practices of us you know having run
these systems at scale but also tapping
into you know our hundreds of ecosystem
partners who are getting excited about
it and contributing back you know as
this matures and I think this is
happening very quickly in the last
couple of years but it really is about
solution delivery and not just
technology delivery with anthos all
these customers moving into products
that skills very exciting and you know
obviously as you said there are security
concerns how are we making that easier
for our customers yeah I mean we've been
you know security is a major
differentiator for us for GCP more
broadly and I think because
containerization is relatively a new
space we've been doing a lot with both
our customers and partners to do number
one you know education and awareness
around container security and secure
software supply chains and things like
binary authorization and CI CD and how
to make sure that security is baked in
way upstream so that when a developer
checks in code essentially it starts the
the you know governance process of
security and it's not a bolt-on
afterthought
after the fact I think that is a lot of
the way that the Google Google
developers are when they check in code
essentially they don't have to be an
expert in security but the platform
takes care of a lot of the complexity of
security and governance thank you so
much for your time Jennifer thanks for
having me got a question or comment on
anthos or kubernetes reach out to us on
social media with the hashtag Google
next nineteen we're gonna stick with the
anthos topic for a bit and head down to
the showcase floor where our team is
demoing a new solution that allows
customers to modernize to containers
[Music]
hey everyone we're here at the
infrastructure migration zone of Google
cloud next I'm mark merchandani I'm here
with Sumatra knot we heard a lot today
about anthos what is anthos why is it so
excited anthos is incredibly exciting
for us at Google cloud we announced an
thoses cloud services platform just over
8 months ago and today we're very
excited to announce general availability
of anthos for our customers to be able
to use it
anthos is our hybrid and multi cloud
platform that gives our customers the
ability to build once and run anywhere
why is hybrid and multi clouds so
important right now
that's a great question mark so hybrid
and multi cloud has been on top of mine
for a lot of our customers they're very
very excited about the ability to use
clouds but oftentimes what happens is
when they're running something on Prem
but running something else in the cloud
it becomes hard for them to manage these
different deployments that make them
segment their workforce into engineers
who are working on different things
instead of focusing on innovating for
their customers so that's why hybrid and
multi cloud is very important and it's
very important to have a uniform
platform like anthos that lets customers
run in a uniform way across the board so
we're talking about standardizing making
sure that everyone's on the same level
for people who are here at the showcase
they can come interact with this booth
what does this tell people who are
looking at what does anthos do for me so
what we have in this demo has we've
taken the analogy of a city and how it
works and we've used that to show how
hybrid and multi cloud is very important
and how anthers helps in that particular
analogy so let's get started so we have
these three things that you can do over
the course of this demo first let's
start off by modernizing your services
there are multiple reasons you would
want to modernize your service for
instance it gives you a lot more agility
and speed and lets you deploy faster so
in this demo there are two options for
how you can modernize your applications
you can either containerize them
manually or you can use CSP migrate
which is now called and force migrate to
be able to migrate these applications
automatically from VM running on Prem
into containers running in the club so
for the sake of this run-through let's
select modernizing with fellow startup
which is and throws my tip so bellow
strata automatically container eise's
your VM based workloads and will deploy
them to gke running in the cloud so just
as easily as that you'll have all of
your via VMs now moved to the cloud as
containers now let's look at the second
part we also help you standardize config
management using anthos config
management what anthos config management
lets you do is it lets you take a single
configuration and deploy it across the
board declaratively and uniformly
without you having to go and do it once
at a time per platform so no matter
whether you are running only on Prem in
Google cloud or maybe even with other
clouds you can do this all at once right
so now it's all standardized so now it's
all standardized and so for the third
part of this demo there's something very
exciting for me which is a service mesh
a service mesh is basically a mechanism
that lets you look deep into the traffic
that's actually flowing between your
applications whether they're on
on-premise or in the cloud in this case
what we're going to do is we're going to
use an tha's to implement a service mesh
between on Prem well here and the two
cloud wills that we have and by doing
this we are able to select a service and
we're able to say that let's update this
service now when you upgrade this
service you pick a new version that you
want to upgrade to but instead of
upgrading everything at once what you're
going to do is you're going to select a
small percentage off your VMs or
workloads and upgrade them at once so
when you do this and you upgrade these
containers at that point in time you
will upgrade just that 20% so that you
see everything is running fine and you
don't have anything broken and once you
are confident that this service is
working well you can upgrade everything
else so this means now we are able to
roll out applications with limited
downtime to almost zero downtime for
your customers so you can see how
anthers uses open source technologies
but also this idea of standardization to
really bring it to everybody yes what's
an example customer or concrete use case
that empty O's has right now great
questions so we have a lot of customers
who've been very excited to use Anton's
and they span multiple verticals like
for instance HSBC from
banking and Siemens who's a giant when
it comes to manufacturing are also
looking at anthos as their platform of
choice for doing IRT and their IOT
platform so there are multiple customers
across verticals like retail and
healthcare who are very excited about
this platform and love that ability to
standardize and have a uniform plan
perfect well thank you so much free nap
I'm sure there's gonna be tons of great
content here about infos and lots of
other stuff ago about neck so stay tuned
[Music]
thanks team check out this next step
bite well we explore how human bias can
sometimes creep into our work without us
realizing it this is Michelle Kaz Bunn
she's an engineer at Google on the cube
flow team and this is John Bohannon he's
the director of science at primer an AI
start-up my team at primer built a
machine learning system that reads
millions of news articles and tells you
what it learns and I worked with them to
deploy this system of cue flow to make
it portable and scalable the goal is to
create a machine to help humans learn
about the world and overcome their
biases humans are biased consider this
riddle a boy and his father are in a car
crash the father is killed instantly
the boy is rushed to the hospital and
prep for surgery with one of the best
doctors in the country the doctor
arrives sees the boy on the table and
says I can't operate on this patient
he's my son who's the doctor it's a
paradox right father's dead so it's the
boy's mother for those playing at home
don't feel bad 85% of people are stumped
by this question it even worked on
Michelle when she first heard it bias is
powerful all humans habits and we all
have to work against it constantly every
time you meet someone you can't help but
make assumptions but you're probably
biased wait that one's actually mine and
that one's mine oh you're totally biased
any system built on human decisions will
inherit human bias consider Wikipedia it
has grown into the world's most
important general-purpose information
resource but there's
no one in charge information is added to
Wikipedia day after day by millions of
volunteers it just boggles the mind that
such a thing can exist and that it
actually works
Wikipedia aims to be the summary of all
human knowledge but it has biases just
like the humans who create it if you
think about all the new things we learn
about the world each day keeping
Wikipedia up to date seems impossible
it's not just that important information
is missing for most articles but it's
that many important articles haven't
been written at all which shouldn't be
that surprising right Wow so there are
about 5 million wikipedia articles in
English alone yep and there are some
thousands of news articles published
every day hundreds of thousands just in
English so you just have to read all of
it you find the important information
that's in one set and doesn't exist in
the other okay yeah that's hard machine
learning to the rescue I decided to
start by focusing on people we want a
system that just reads all the news
every day and learns new information
about everyone not only people described
in Wikipedia but anyone described in the
news and if there's enough significant
information about someone in the news
who's missing from Wikipedia the system
should just write you the first draft of
the article the goal is to make it as
easy as possible for the human editors
of Wikipedia to do their job and the
first step is to shine a really bright
light so we can see where our bias is
for example well for example only about
15% of Wikipedia's biographical articles
are about women and that gender gap is
especially bad for scientists if you
never hear about all the amazing women
of science and engineering then it
reinforces your bias about those
professions exactly and that's why I
wanted to work with primer on this in
the first place right and here we are
just a few weeks later and we're
actually catching up on where we are
with deployment so where we left off we
had this really cool ml system with some
really classic ml deployment problems
cue blow to the rescue our first problem
was scaling so the computing load is all
over the map on this one
on any given day were like processing
hundreds of thousands of documents news
articles scientific papers
and we're updating information about
people in our knowledge base but we also
have users who might want to add
thousands of new people all at once
and that kicks off a backfill of
information about those people from
millions of historical documents this
turned out to be easy to solve because
your team had already set up a
kubernetes cluster a cute flow is built
on kubernetes because scalability is
baked into the platform so the
application back-end was built on top of
Postgres which was a straightforward
migration into cloud sequel once the
data was migrated I transplanted the
full app into kubernetes engine I
started with a single node cluster and
enabled auto provisioning which scales
the size of the cluster up and down
based on resource requests so now we can
deal with unpredictable and bursty
computing loads like yours ok but on top
of the scaling problem I have also got a
complexity problem so our data pipeline
has a bunch of spaghetti junctions and
not only do we have thousands of models
to load at inference time but we have to
update those models as new information
comes in so at training it adds up to
like millions of model features getting
updated every day I noticed that luckily
this is exactly what queue flow is
designed for composability the platform
provides patterns for reusing common ml
tasks like updating models incrementally
in the background I started by carving
out pieces of the app for example model
training was refactored into a separate
service that uses queue flow operators
the monolith is now separated into
smaller distinct pieces now it's a
pipeline with three separate steps train
serve and web app oh that sounds much
nicer okay so how's it looking so far
well the refactoring immediately reduced
the training run time so that translates
directly to cost savings and now you
don't have to run huge nodes all the
time because gke takes care of the
scaling for you the other win is the
decrease in code complexity that
translates to less maintenance overhead
less time searching for the source of
bugs less time on ramping new engineers
and adding new features okay but that
creates a new problem what happened I
thought of so you know now we have all
this save time what am I going to do
with all my time you could create some
Wikipedia articles about women of
science hmm good call
oh and what about the last thing on my
wish list about vendor lock-in we don't
want our system tied to one cloud
infrastructure we want it to be able to
deploy anywhere even on Prem oh and
bonus points if the solution is free and
open source check and check as long as
you're running standard open source
kubernetes you can run kids oh wait key
flows open source oh thanks for
listening I hope that hearing about this
project
lowers the bar for trying it yourself
the cube flow community has some great
resources for getting started which you
can find at cube flow org and hey got a
few minutes every time I've already used
this machine learning system to identify
thousands of notable women of science
who are missing from Wikipedia you can
make a difference right now just follow
this link and see what the machine is
discovered for you go fill in a gap in
the world's knowledge eliminating human
bias with cue flow can be useful in
every industry you can watch all the
live stream content again or share it
with your friends and colleagues at GTO
slash next on air now start working up
an appetite because right after the next
sessions we're experimenting with pizza
and pie stay tuned you're watching the
next live show from San Francisco
[Music]
welcome everyone we are here at the dead
zone at the Pizza Authenticator app
Terry tell me what am I looking at here
I was promised pie all I see is pizza
what's what's going on it is a form of
pie right so we have an app here that
will authenticate pizza to a certain
region in the country right like we have
New York Pizza of California Pizza
Chicago pizza this app will judge how
authentic it is for what style it's
supposed to be okay interesting so uh
why don't you actually what do you show
us how it works so we have our pizza
here and we have our tablet here make
sure it's in focus and bam
and now Pizza Authenticator is judging
whether or not this pizza is authentic
it's chewing on it and we see that it is
pretty confident that this is New York
style pizza and so definitely pizza
probably from New York okay okay let's
so let's check out this IV that's so
good looking fine there's more Midwest
so let's see
make sure it's in focus do it again
she's taking a bite out of that Chicago
style pizza her style so it's good now
we'll finish I'm curious to what Tess
knows the hit knows what it is I can't
think of any pie that deserves to have
zucchini on it but yeah well here in the
wonderful Golden State's we make
abominations yes California yes so it
knew it was California pizza excellent
well I mean I'm a huge supporter of
anything that involves this amount of
pizza yeah but tell me what's the point
of this like why is this in the dead
zone we got this so this uses under the
covers mm right machine learning and m/l
is really daunting right like a lot of
people come to it like they think they
need to be as like a data scientist to
do it and you're rank-and-file
developers sometimes you know can't
approach it well we took kind of an
incredibly trivial use of ml and trained
it to like determine whether or not
pizza was authentic okay and all of all
of this we did like we grabbed the data
we classified all the images it was all
done by me
who is an app dev not a data scientist
so it really shows that anyone could do
a Mel if I can do it like anyone can do
so you could take the same sort of
technology the same approach here and
really apply it to much more meaningful
projects right if you wanted to you know
take pictures of satellite pictures of
forests and see how they change over
time and see you identify trees from the
forest for the trees right like you
could do that with this and that's a
much more serious you know application
of this but it's the same principle
pizza on on the forest absolutely no and
it's it's a fun way to approach machine
learning that's sort of certainly
fantastic
all right now I believe the real pie is
over with mark so we're gonna we're
gonna dig into some of this so you pick
your favorite style piece so I'm gonna
go for the authenticated New York style
I'm going from New York oh yeah it's
it's it's hard not to
so we'll dig into this and we're gonna
cross over to you for dessert mark
whether it's pizza pie or anything else
round you can't calculate the
circumference without knowing about 3.14
also known as pie but there's a few more
digits than that so let's talk to Emma
and see how she broke the world record
for calculating 31 point four trillion
digits using Google cloud platform so
Emma how did you do it program cruncher
for four months on Google cloud platform
and we set up a cluster of 25 machines
and we made sure that these machines run
continuously we have any shutdowns of
reboots for 100 days yeah I mean that's
no easy feat 120 days all those machines
running non-stop that's kind of
something magical right yeah but Google
has all the features and mechanisms to
make sure these machines and software
are running and we saw the moistening
systems and other techniques that that
we use for production servers because
normally speaking it's very difficult to
keep one process running over 151 days
nonetheless on 24 machines right so what
inspired you to kind of look for this
many digits apart like humanity
collectively tried to calculate as many
digits of pi as possible since like 2000
BC and even the first electronic
computer ENIAC was to use the kekkai
2000 days of Pi and
them pie was used as a benchmark to
measure the performance and reliability
of computers and now we use a Google
cloud
so that means Chloe is capable of doing
this kind of heavy duty work that's
awesome to see and congratulations on
breaking the world record of course
there's more than just numbers in pi we
can also use it to make art let's talk
to Mattias about how he managed to do
really really cool generative art using
all of Emma's work Mattias tell me a
little bit more about what you've done
here
right so 31 trillion digits is a huge
number right right but not only is it a
lot of numbers what's really interesting
about pi it's also that the sequence
never repeats itself so we thought like
what could we do with this so we came up
with this we made this algorithm that
would turn these sequences of Pi into a
visual representation essentially and
this allows people to find 31 trillion
different visual representations of Pi
somewhere within pi take a look
absolutely so we can jump to any digit
within by that we want I'll just type in
a random number so from that point on it
takes the next several thousand digits
of pi then being unique within there and
then generate a piece of art out of this
essentially so if anyone else is here
they can come by they can change up the
numbers and they'll see a different
artwork because it's unique sets of Pi
pattern exactly so someone could come by
say like they type in their phone
numbers we're like maybe the birthday
the birthday if they're you know their
spouse or whatnot and time to save and
then essentially get a unique
representation of that number within pi
very very cool this is just one of the
many cool experiments that we have here
at the dev zone
so hopefully the people here can come
check it out and see all the cool work
that we've done thanks very much mark if
you are hungry to try these experiments
head to gqo slash showcase slash
experiments now we don't have to tell
you how important mobile is to how we
work connect and play in this next step
bite we're going under the hood to show
you how an ml kit can be used for
building mobile apps
it seems machine learning is everywhere
nowadays and missed so many offerings
for you as a mobile developer it can get
really confusing as to where
you should start I'm Mariah maluca an
engineer on the firebase team and I'm
here today to introduce you to the
options that are available to you if we
could carry data centers in our pocket
with unlimited battery it would be much
easier but using ml for mobile apps
means thinking about the processing
power battery consumption and
connectivity of our device there are a
number of factors that will dictate the
amount energy and tools you'll want to
use like whether you want to keep the
data local if you require low latency or
if you need access to the processing
power of the cloud luckily Google offers
a number of EMA options for mobile
developers that can help you develop and
deploy ml models for the environment
that fits your use case to help you pick
which ml deployment option fits best
I'll walk you through it pqube the
season points the first question you
should ask yourself is where you want to
perform email inferences in the cloud or
on the device you would use the cloud if
you are already using an existing cloud
service for model inferences or you run
inferences infrequently and want to
minimize impact on the device battery
life or need to support older less
performant devices or if you need high
accuracy models that require to compute
power of the cloud on the other hand
there are cases in which it might be
useful to do email inference on the
mobile device for example if you want to
keep data local to the device you need
low latency such as RAM processing
multiple frames in quick succession you
want inferences to work even when the
devices of line or your users may be in
an area of the world where high-speed
wireless connectivity is non-existent or
unreliable so now that you understand
all the considerations let me present
the
available to you first is to run in
France in the cloud and there's a world
of tools and API so you can use these
include cloud vision for image
recognition and classification cloud
natural language API for text parsing
and analysis auto ml that allows you to
customize models that are served from
the cloud all are available via REST API
I won't go into them all here but you
can learn more it cloud.google.com slash
products /ai slash building that blocks
next is to run inference on device and
you have two main options you can either
use TF light directly or you can use a
milk it for firebase a mark is a mobile
sdk that brings Google's machine
learning experience to Android and iOS
apps in a powerful yet easy to use
package it comes with a set of
ready-to-use api's both for on device
and cloud base inference they support
common mobile use cases like image
labeling face detection text recognition
and parkour scanning to name a few you
simply pass in the data to their market
library and it will give you the
information you need whether you are new
to or experienced with machine learning
you can implement the functionality you
need all in a few lines of code and it
includes both Android and iOS libraries
wild own device api's process data
quickly and Millward even when there is
no need for connection the cloud pays
api's leverage the power of google cloud
platforms machine learning technology to
give a higher level of accuracy if you
have a use case that's different than
offered models and alkyl also offers the
ability to deploy an experiment with
your own custom tensorflow light models
to run on device inference
it works like this after converting your
model to the TF light format you can
host and serve it to your users and I'll
get four firebase can then be used toast
and dynamically served here flight
models to your users and it provides
convenient API that help you use your
custom TF flight models in your mobile
apps with Americans for fire ways you
can reduce the initial install size of
your mobile app and only download the
model where needed dynamically swap
models on the fly without having to
republish your app to the App Store
target different user segments with
models tailored specifically for them
run a B experiments with multiple models
to find the best performing one if you'd
like you can also use your TF flight
model or mobile directly with clear
flight api's these offer blazingly fast
inference times particularly on Android
devices that support the neural network
api's and a variety of ways to host and
deploy your model for mobile developers
looking to implement machine learning
into their apps
there are several directions to choose
depending on how much flexibility you
want or have specific you'll your use
cases recover some key factors that help
you decide like whether you do your
inference on the device or in the cloud
and whether you want to use the pre
trained models Google provides or train
and bring your custom model check out
our full session app next for a deep
dive analysis live experiments and the
latest ml offerings from Google if you
want to see more on ml options for
mobile developers check out the full
session on chico / NEX on air
Google cloud is becoming an integral
part of how retail business can quickly
scale and connect with customers let's
head back to the showcase floor where
joanna is checking out how IKEA uses
Google cloud to improve customer service
[Music]
welcome back to the showroom floor I'm
really excited to be here because now
I'm over in the customer magic zone and
it's really really cool
but right now I'm standing with Klaus
who is a senior engineer for IKEA and
he's going to show us one of the most
popular demos in the area there are
crowds of people trying to fight their
way in right now hey back up I'm looking
at you but so before you actually show
me how it works
can you tell me a little bit about how
your team developed this yeah sure so we
assembled a pretty small team that
working working and it's iterative
fashion that's dividing the work but
close feedback loops together with
Google engineering yeah we used a vision
API product search yes it's awesome
together with object detection that
we're trying out together with Google to
enhance the product offering from
yourself and also you know try to work
with the customer experience on our site
so you'll see in the demo okay and then
you talked about how your team really
focused on working iteratively
now I heard remember that you all did
this whole thing in less than three
weeks that's pretty amazing yeah fast
paced very short Sprint's that we did
right so you got to work with you
mentioned some Google engineers which is
really cool but you also you get to work
for a company that like really
encourages and gives you the space to
try these ideas so quickly like that how
does that feel like as a developer
that's really good right that we we are
empowered to do this kind of exploration
cases it sounds like a dream yeah it
really is
ok so speaking of dreams will you show
me how this works maybe on the horse
right sure sure so this is here we try
to detect object yeah and then it
matches to arrange right and then you
can interact with it and it will show
you our mobile webpage where it is yet
more information
and then could you do like this stool
yeah sure so let's try it out it will
recognize it and show direct it's a
yawning it stool and then we can see it
is that instead of taking that little
pencil you can walk around for that
quick does it you think it likes
decorative items of course of course so
let's try this one out so you see here I
got directly this is so cheap and it's a
plant I can't go because it's fake it's
a man called fake what are you really
yeah is that Spanish for fake oh my gosh
one so badly this is a really cool demo
I understand now why there's a crowd of
people waiting to get back in here know
what so I want to thank you so much for
talking to me a fan for building it
thanks for having us man I am so excited
I will be in the store pretty soon and
then thanks to all of y'all for watching
and we'll show you some more cool things
later after the next round of sessions
Radle will be checking out the v 9
lounge with dave renson director of cre
and network capacity
they'll be chatting about how cre it
helps improve reliability you won't want
to miss it you're watching the next live
show in San Francisco
[Music]
welcome back to the next live show
coming up later today on next favorite
the developer keynote titled get to the
fun part
I'm definitely setting my alarm for this
one but first let's head to the v 9
lounge where radio and dave rensen
director of cre and network capacity are
hanging up
[Music]
so Dave we meet again it was just what
nine months ago that you and I were
hanging out here at the fifth nine
lounge at next we were talking about
your new book I think so what have you
been up to since we last spoke
you know it's cloud it's only one of
Google's fastest growing businesses so
not much really you know video games
rock climbing a lot of quinoa mostly
that sounds about right pretty sedate
anything anything work-related yeah I
mean lots of stuff mostly working with
customers and doing everything we can to
teach the world what it means to be an
SRE and how to do it well so when
attendees come to next what can they
expect when they visit us here in their
59 lounge well really what we're hoping
for is to have those deep conversations
about how it is they go on their SRA
journey we're still kind of at this
stage where we have to really prove to
people that no this is not just
something that only works at Google they
can work anywhere ok let's get down to
business and get to the nitty-gritty of
SRA how do we help customers move
towards implementing SRA practices I
also there two things you really have to
do one you have to make it easy for them
to learn right so we wrote these two
best-selling books so we have a Coursera
course with a lot of writing and public
speaking and then you have to make it
easy for them to practice it in the
tools right so there's a wonderful
announcement today from a stackdriver
team about SLO alerting and era budget
monitoring so those are really two
things two ways you have to attack that
problem
fantastic so what is Google doing to
help our customers make their own SOS
you know I think the best thing a
customer can do to reliably meet s ellos
besides building good products it's
actually share their monitoring with
Google like if you're using stackdriver
you set up an SLO dashboard you can
actually share that with us so that when
you have difficult moments and you will
it becomes faster for everyone to debug
and so what is people - what is Google
doing with our products to help
customers implement those SLO and our
budgets themselves my personal Goulet
goal at Google is to make sure that it's
easy in every product to practice sre
principles that roll outs and roll backs
are item potent and easy when you're
doing them on I don't know GC GC E or GK
you saw the announcement this morning of
our new kubernetes hybrid and on-prem
solution we're gonna make some other
announcements about SLO monitoring and
burn monitoring in those solutions too
so we're really building at every layer
of the stack fantastic now hanging out
with the few sres hear a lot about
accepting failure is normal how do you
recommend customers go about moving from
every error is a problem to the mindset
of failure is normal you know a big
problem is that for so long we've all
been living under the tyranny of
perfection we expect perfection and I
always say to customers tell me one
system designed by humans software
hardware economic political anything you
want that's ever been a hundred percent
reliable and they can't and you know why
they can't because nature's never built
one either so once you accept that it's
not possible to do then the question
becomes well how much failure is
acceptable because you've got to have
some and that's where then we get into
the conversations about error budgets
nestlings that's a good segue so how do
you see customers becoming effective at
managing the workloads of their sre
things ok so you know there are some
good rule of thumb limits about the
number incidents you can really have
during an on call period or how much for
your project time you can have so I
think a good rule of thumb for people is
if you see your team's are spending at
all anything less than 50% of their
calendar time their clock time on
engineering projects they're headed for
toil and they're not managing the load
well but we can you come talk to us we
can help you manage your way through
that absolutely and so speaking of that
you know what are your recommendation to
customers on how to take that first step
of their journey towards sre well there
are a bunch of things you can do we've
got two two best-selling books if you go
to google.com /soe can read both of the
books for free we have a course on
Coursera specifically on SL O's that's
really very popular if you're here at
the show come by v 9 and talk to us
Ari's talk to me or anyone else
if you're a Google cloud customer you
can talk for free with the Siri team the
customer reliability engineering team we
are a group of long tenured esterase and
our job is to teach you how to adopt
essary and make that easy and
comfortable for you
fantastic thanks Dave it is always a
pleasure thank you right oh yeah now
remember if you're here at next come and
join us at the fifth nine lounge and
talk to a bunch of sres
all about your sree questions and now
we'll send it over to you Stephanie
thanks red oh and Dave throughout the
next live show we're bringing you
condensed versions of a few next
sessions that we're calling dev fights
watch this next up byte to learn how to
surface problems and how to fix them
using stackdriver
as you move to the cloud and adopt the
latest technology such as kubernetes
have you found it even harder to find
the root cause of issues and understand
just how well your application is
performing stack driver application
performance management aka APM shines
light on your cloud native and multi
cloud environments in order to help you
solve these problems better i am brian
zimmerman
product manager for trace & debugger and
i'm morgan mcclain product manager for
stack driver profiler stack driver is
Google's suite of management and
observability products APM is focused on
that deeper levels of debug style
information to help reduce mean time to
resolution find performance
optimizations and build the best
possible experience for your users APM
features three products stack driver
trace stack driver profiler and stack
driver debugger traces are distributing
tracing product what is distributed
tracing you ask well tracing allows you
to visualize how a request flows through
your environment in microservices
applications or highly distributed
environments understanding context and
flow is essential to resolving problems
how do we use this in real life
for example let's assume that we receive
an alert that shows a jump in latency
for our application trace gives us the
best detailed data to help us up
troubleshoot this error with stackdriver
trace you can easily see the top
requests RPC calls and associated
latency
find an example of the issue you're
having with simple search and filter and
see a simple view of the request as a
processes through your complex
environment this includes detailed
custom information and annotations for
more detailed information analysis
reports are generated automatically you
can view an existing report or create
your own to see how latency has changed
over time you can group these by
percentile and you can also drill down
and into example traces to find out
exactly what happened to cause this
issue as you can see trace guides you
from problem to service now we will show
you how you can get from service to
method with stackdriver profiler
profiler can inspect the CPU and memory
performance of all the functions in your
code and it shows you the calling
relationships between them profiler can
visualize your code on a flame graph
which shows calling relationships along
the vertical axis and resource
consumption on the horizontal axis you
can use a number of different filters
including weight filtering which only
shows data captured during periods of
high consumption and a focus filter
which shows all the paths in and out of
a selected function if you need to
visualize the performance of functions
that are called to write your code base
you can use the focus table which shows
the aggregated cost of all the functions
in the graph finally once you've
identified the area of code that you're
interested in it's time to inspect the
behavior of this code to find the
problem this is where debugger comes in
stackdriver debugger offers the ability
to take LOC points and snapshots of your
running code in production without
impact redeploying or restarting your
services
traditionally debugging involves
analyzing logs and metrics taking a
guess at the problem deploying some new
code or a debug module looking at the
logs again to confirm waiting for the
issue analyzing logs again perhaps
taking another crack at it
stackdriver to bugger allows you to take
breakpoints and snapshots in production
without system impact redeploying or
restarting your application this allows
you to tighten your troubleshooting flow
significantly as you're not having to
wait for lengthy deployments
in addition to the efficiency gains many
customers report being able to bring
debugging further up the troubleshooting
stack to operators or sres further
reducing MTTR
an affecting customer impact all of
these APM tools work of code and apps
that are running on any cloud or even
on-premise infrastructure so no matter
where you run your application you now
have a consistent accessible APM toolkit
to monitor and manage the performance of
your apps with stack driver trace
profiler and debugger APM enables
developers and operators to track and
resolve issues the way that Google site
reliability engineering does you can
start and stop your code without
affecting your users and get insights
into how your code is running on
production no matter what cloud you're
using whether your application is just
getting off the ground or if it's
already live and in production using APM
to monitor and tuna's performance can be
a game-changer to get started or
stackdriver APM simply link the
appropriate libraries for each tool to
your application and then start
gathering telemetry for analysis to
learn more visit cloud.oracle.com
[Music]
welcome back to the next live show
thanks for joining us I'm Stephanie Wong
and I'm ready Maya Stephanie and I have
had a blast here next 19 so far and it's
been great sharing the experience with
you if you missed anything across the
last two days head to geocode slash next
on air and watch all the content with
live streaming across the six channels
billed run analyze and learn secure
collaborate and the next live show the
developer keynote is just around the
corner so to warm up for the event we've
asked our colleagues marissa root and
dave stan key to take us on a grand tour
of the developer zone check this out
hi there I'm Marisa and I'm Dave and we
work on the Google developer relations
team we're here at the dead zone which
is the ecosystem for developers here at
Google cloud next right now at dev zone
theater we're hosting a panel discussion
with the authors of go this is an
interactive session where people can
learn about the language and find out
what's coming next
come with us as we explore the rest of
the desktop let's go
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey st. banana excellent perfect we got
one
how's it look I think it's looking
pretty good actually
whoa I'm getting my snaps on here at the
network journey experiment where we're
showcasing the speed and breadth of
Google's worldwide network what's going
on here Carrie well exactly so we're
demonstrating here how Google's
investment in infrastructure allows our
customers to move their data around the
world without having to access the
public internet it it's fast and it's
secure and what is taking selfies have
to do with it taking selfies so just
like when you travel and you get stamps
in your passport we're actually taking
the data that makes up your picture and
as it passes through these different
regions and these data centers we stamp
it with that location so when it comes
to background to the destination we took
these pictures then we have actual proof
that your data moved through all these
data centers it's really cool as my
picture made it around the world yet oh
let's see
it did it has all right looking good
and the worse for wear thank you thanks
so much for talking with me today could
you share a little bit what you and your
team are up to here in the devs um so
I'm from the developer relations
ecosystem team and we are informing
people here about the different
community problems that we have in the
area of cloud awesome so what type of
programs do you have that people can
take advantage of so we basically have
three programs so the Google developer
experts they ambassador in a specific
area of Technology we have the Google
developer groups also local meetups that
you can go to all over the globe and we
also have the women techmakers that's a
program that increases diversity so
specifically there are programs that
people can take advantage of in
different communities all over the globe
yes you can basically everywhere you go
you can go to meet up you can meet a
Google developer experts and talk to
them about your area of interest awesome
thank you so much for your time thank
you
it's 3:14 here in the dead zone and that
means it's pie time we're celebrating
because a fellow Googler of mine Emma
Hakka
Yao recently broke the Guinness world
record for number of digits of pi
calculated using cloud computing for the
first time to compute thirty-one point
four trillion digits of pi that's a lot
of pie I'm gonna get my celebration on
[Music]
hi there I'm here with Paris at one of
the community corners hey Paris has gone
it's going good are you Bert I'm good
what do you do here I am a Google cloud
open-source strategist I work on
upstream kubernetes I'm a co-chair the
special interest group for contributor
experience and what makes kubernetes
unique the community definitely I think
we have one of the largest contributing
communities and I think it's important
to get customers to participate and that
and that's why I'm here today
awesome and what have you been doing
while you've been here at the tip zone
playing arcade game play it's been
wonderful like watching awesome speakers
and meeting all some contributors it's
been great to have all this in one spot
we showed you just a few cool
interactive experiences here at Google
cloud X but you don't have to be here in
person to check this out you can visit
all of these experiences and more at
Chico slash showcase in addition we're
right in front of hands-on lab you don't
need to be here to do that
you can do it right now with quick laps
get certified learn all about Google
products and get started today
and be sure to subscribe to the Google
cloud platform YouTube channel thank you
so much for joining us here at the desk
we really appreciate it
[Music]
thanks for the tour Marissa and Dave
it's cool to see a space dedicated to
developers joining is now our developer
advocates Rachel Chapman and Sarah
Robinson to set the stage for what's in
store during the developer keynote
welcome Rachel please kick us off by
describing kaggle Cagle is the home of
data science so you might know us for
our supervised machine learning
competitions and we still do that but
right now we have a lot more on the side
so we've got public data sets that
anyone can use
if you want to analyze your own data you
can upload it privately you know not
tear it out and we also have a hosted
jupiter development environment so that
includes GPU acceleration offered at no
charge and we just upgraded from k 80s
to p 100 so if you're looking for a
little bit of like speed it can be a
nice nice little added bonus great and
how our data scientists and analysts
utilizing kaggle to support their
machine learning projects yeah a lot of
different ways so the thing I think
that's probably most unique about kaggle
is we have a really big community about
2.7 million registered users and we have
a super active forum so it can be really
hard to find information about your
specific questions especially machine
learning and AI and things are moving so
quickly so having a community that you
can go to and ask questions and learn
together is a really fantastic resource
and Sarah have you used cattle in your
work and seen its benefits in the ML
community yes I use Cagle almost every
day and always looking for interesting
datasets for machine learning demos and
kaggle is my go-to for that you can find
almost any type of data set you're
looking for images text structured data
on coggle so it's been a great tool for
me what what ml a I want to say you most
excited about and tell me a little bit
about why there's some auto now launches
that I'm super excited about really
making it easy for anyone to use machine
learning without having to have machine
learning expertise so the first I'll
talk about is Auto ml tables which makes
it really easy to build custom machine
learning models on structured data so
think about anything you might be able
to put in a spreadsheet categorical data
a numerical data building models on that
with Auto ml tables that's really easy
upload your data to the UI has to Train
button and your models ready to go
another Auto ml launch I'm super excited
about is Auto ml vision object detection
so Auto ml vision can already
do classification but now what you'll be
able to do is identify regions in your
image where a certain label exists so it
will return bounding boxes so I'm super
excited about about those auto now
launches and we're about to see a
showcase highlighting our work with the
n-c-double-a using bigquery ml what can
you tell us about bigquery ml
specifically bqm l let's folks that have
structured data stored in bigquery a bit
crazed our cloud data analytics
warehouse so it lets you create machine
learning models on that data stored in
bigquery just with a single sequel query
so you don't have to move your data out
of bigquery to use it it's super simple
to use so you just write a query your
models train and then you can write
another query to generate a prediction I
actually give a session on B QML earlier
today with one of our customers Triple A
that's using BQ ml to predict call
volumes across their call centers great
and Rachel have you also heard about BQ
mo on the launch - yeah definitely
and I checked out the instalaciones one
thing that I found really exciting was
student developers we're working on
developing new features for analyzing
basketball games so one of them was
clutchless
like how many points you're gonna score
in the last five minutes and I thought
that was super interesting because on
cago we've hosted n-c-double-a
competitions where you predict the
winning team and it was a couple years
ago one of the very high placers had
just used linear regression which is
available in a big cute big query ml let
me say all the words correctly and also
these custom features that they've
developed so I'm seeing some interesting
synergy there this is a perfect time to
check in with our colleague Joanna Smith
who earlier had a chance to stop by our
NCAA showcase demo
[Music]
I'm sorry Anna and I'm here in the
industry solutions neighborhood of our
expo floor looking at this great energy
all these people are really excited and
I'm standing with the lock who's gonna
show us the n-c-double-a demo gonna take
it away yeah so this is our second year
at Google cloud being the official cloud
provider of the n-c-double-a our theme
is know what your data knows so we've
been working with the actual
n-c-double-a data basketball data to
make a lot of insights and predictions
so let's so get one we just had a
national title game Virginia and Texas
Tech and what we're looking at here is
the number of possessions each team will
have in regulation so we predicted that
the number will be 63 or fewer and it
was 59 in regulation so it was right
well we've done a bunch more so one of
the other things we did was we looked at
a data studio dashboard so data studio
another tool made by Google allows you
to visualize your data yeah we have
developed a bunch of different metrics
for all these teams in n-c-double-a you
can see them on the bottom here score
control clutch nest discipline etc but
we wanted to surface that data in a way
that people could use filter and sort so
this has all the 353 teams but if we
just want to look at the champion we can
go here and select champion only boom
Virginia and now we can see where they
ranked in all the different categories
yeah there's a good sport for clutchless
yeah so the ranks are right there so you
can tell it's seventh out of three
hundred fifty-three teams pretty good a
third and sport control they very
deserving campaign so you said this is
data studio which we know is for
visualization which is really cool but
have you missed some other cloud tools I
think bigquery played a big part in this
yeah show me how that works yeah so the
first thing we have to do is write make
a pipeline to ingest the data so this is
a small screen here but I'll show you
this is on our Google cloud blog we
describe the entire pipeline of how we
built this data and you can see there's
a bunch of stuff and then we get to
bigquery right in the middle and I'm a
data scientist I want stuff in bigquery
because then I can go and do all my
stuff right so bigquery let's do it and
then what we do from there is we take
the data we do a lot of manipulations
and to build that metric like score
control we have to write a bunch of code
alright so got the cloud blog and then
you also post it on medium right yeah
more fun insight yeah so on medium what
we did was we wanted to talk more in
depth about how we built this metric so
one we wanted to describe in detail for
the technical people but also talking
about the basketball
so you have this thing how the final
score can lie score control right and in
here we go through a couple example
games where teams control the score
differently but then again we get back
to bigquery so here is a long query and
again it looks fairly complicated and it
kind of is but it actually is when you
think about how you go about doing this
calculation bigquery makes it pretty
easy with these aggregation functions
and it runs really fast and it may be
long but it's easy to read and and it
runs really fast gets us our results for
all thousands of games in a matter of
seconds and then we can move forward and
do other stuff
I love scale power now you did one more
thing in this blog right at the bottom I
thought I was playing with your what was
that an interactive scatter watch we
keep going here eventually we get to a
point where we see this scatter plot
which spots all 353 teams in their
school colors and shows their difference
between the score control and a
different mesh I like it so if anyone
wants to kind of find out at home they
can search n-c-double-a on our cloud
blog or they can look cross link this is
the cloud showcase yeah GCO / March
Madness oh nice I know it's a little bit
past March but the tournament is so
fresh in the mind so it should it should
be should be fun to look at well thank
you so much for talking to me Wow
amazing showcase how is bigquery ml
changing the game for machine learning
for developers and practitioners good
question
two things that come to mind for me
first of all being able to work in
sequel so something we found in our cago
machine learning developers survey is
that sequel is actually the third most
commonly used language for machine
learning so and also people who are
outside of the machine learning AI space
we're just coming into it many of them
are already familiar with sequel so
being able to use tools that you already
know how to use is a really big time
saver and also you don't have to
download data locally so if you've got
sensitive data that you can't store
locally or it's just like really big and
you can't store it on disk being able to
do your question and bigquery instead of
having to download everything your
Python code and then upload everything
once you've changed your model I can be
a big time saver and to add to that I
think peak UML is a great entry point
for machine learning so you don't have
to worry about any sort of feature
engineering so if you have categorical
data for example if you're building a
model yourself you would have to one
hotting code that
two arrays BQ ml can recognize that it's
a categorical column and transform your
data for you
democratization of data has been a big
theme at Google we really believe that
if you want innovation you have to
democratize access data can you talk a
little about how bigquery ml and auto ml
are having an impact towards us being
able to achieve that goal yeah
definitely
so both BQ ml and auto ml make it easy
for anyone regardless of your machine
learning expertise to build your own
custom machine learning models so you
don't need a lot of machine learning
expertise to get started you just upload
your data choose the type of model you
want and both BQ ml and auto ml will
handle the rest and Auto amel
specifically you don't need as much
later date labeled data as well so I
know the natural language API I'm sorry
the natural language auto mo that just
launched you only need 100 label
examples per category for for each label
in your categorical Learning example
which is very little data especially
when you're looking at like imported or
Alma or these really really enormous gbt
to enormous language models so being
able to get started with relatively
little data smaller time investment
smaller money investment for labeling is
a really big movement towards
democratization great so you'll actually
be talking about the past from Cloud
Auto ml to custom model in your breakout
session can you give us a preview of the
key factors when moving from auto ml
into custom ml models yeah definitely so
the goal of our breakout session
tomorrow I'm gonna be speaking with you
thing is to teach people that may not
have built their own custom model before
how to get started because at least for
me the process of starting to learn how
to build a custom model is really
intimidating there's lots of resources
out there it's hard to know where to get
started so we're gonna break it down
talk about feature transformations
feature engineering that you need to do
to go from auto ml to custom model and
walk through some code and they'll also
be a couple live demos Rachel you'll
also be leading a session tomorrow using
Google's data and AI technologies with
cattle
what sort of things will you cover and
what part of it are you most excited
about so we are going to get people
two of kegels a lot of things have
changed recently and they're also going
to talk about several integrations that
we've maybe some we and honestly the one
that I'm most excited about is the
ability to take cattle dataset and
launch it as a Sheetz instance a Google
sheets instance with a single click of a
button and one place where I think this
could actually be extremely useful for
people is for project management so
you're writing a kernel in a notebook
and you or you're generating let's say
you're hyper parameter search space you
save that as a data set you want it as a
sheet and then you can you assign action
items linked to other kernels use chats
use color coding which you would want to
do at a CSV but can be really super
useful for project management so I'm
very excited about that integration
Thanks
thank you so much Rachel and Sarah
thanks for having us we'd love to hear
from you watching online so send us your
questions and comments with the hashtag
Google next nineteen that's a wrap for
today be sure to join us tomorrow
starting at 9:00 a.m. Pacific time for
our final day at Google cloud next 19
the day will start with morning sessions
then stephanie and i will chat with adam
Seligmann vice president of developer
relations be sure to check out all the
live stream content from the last two
days all on demand at juco slash next
on-air the keynote is about to start
let's head over there now
[Music]